on parle de cette cérémonie aux
invalides après plusieurs jours de
polémique
un hommage solennel a donc été rendu aux
soldats morts au burkina faso en
libérant les otages avec des images
fortes celles des cercueils des deux
commandos marine porté par leurs frères
d'armes au visage masqué celle des
gestes du président la république pour
tenter de réconforter les familles on
s'arrête un instant sur ces images sont
celles des cercueils qui quittent la
cour des invalides
les militaires en tenant à capella loin
de chez nous en afrique cher aux troupes
de marine un centre est moulé un tel
moment patriotique
ça fait taire toutes les polémiques oui
d'autant qu'il me semble bon il ya eu
des polémiques parce qu'il y en a
toujours mais il me semble que c'est cet
épisode info héroïque et tragique a
plutôt créé des interrogations chez tout
le monde a dit viser tout le monde c'est
à dire que les gens se sont interrogés
sur le décalage immense qui existent
entre nos existences entre nos
polémiques qui sont souvent virtuel et
entre la réalité de ces deux soldats qui
sont formés depuis des années pour mener
ce type d'action et on n'y pense pas on
ne le sait pas toujours je pense que
tout le monde ne connaissait pas le
commando hubert comment commence à
fonctionner et donc il ya une espèce de
résurgence de vertus que
l'individualisme contempora évacuent un
peu facilement ou que l'on s'approprie
encore une fois très souvent
virtuellement parce que les réseaux
sociaux sont devenus une part importante
de l'existence sociale aujourd'hui et
que l'on s'approprie très facilement et
là on s'aperçoit qu'une action
véritablement héroïque est très très
éloignées de ce que nous jugeons
d'habitude donc moi il me semble que les
polémiques sont quand même restés ils
ont eu lieu mais elles sont restées en
deçà d'un même pas de l'émotion mais de
l'interrogation presque existentielle
qui a pu exister je crois que cet
événement est comme celui de beltrame la
mort d'arnaud beltrame peut-être un peu
comme l' incendie de notre dame de paris
un moment où un pays s'interroge sur ses
le titre de l'édito trèbes aude arnaud
de la grange ce matin sur ce qui nous
lie et je crois que cette interrogation
était dans toutes les familles dans tout
les foyers dans toutes les conversations
se ce week-end cet hommage nous rappelle
une dernière chose c'est comment dire la
beauté impressionnante de la liturgie le
funéraire militaires dans le décor
extraordinaire de la cour des invalides
ou là on a une chose s'impose c'est le
silence et le recueillement tout
simplement je vais vous donner la parole
aux uns et aux autres et qu'on écoute un
autre extrait c'est celui du président
qui rend hommage aux soldats et décrit
l'opération rapidement les otages furent
extraits mais l'ennemi tir à bout
portant
le maître cédric de pierrepont et le
maître alain berton selo tombèrent la
mission était un succès mais nos deux
soldats n'étaient plus
il était mort en héros pour la france
mort en héros
parce que pour eux rien n'est plus
important que la mission
rien de plus précieux que la vie des
otages yves duhamel il dit il ya eu des
polémiques notamment celle sur le fait
d'aller faire du tourisme dans des zones
à risque elle avait lieu d'être et puis
celle de la présence du chef de l'état
et du chef d'état major des armées à
l'arrivée des décors aux à villacoublay
des otages pardon à villacoublay
qu'est-ce qui c'est derrière nous
maintenant c'est inévitable
ces vins où il ya matière à
effectivement discuté mouvements d'yeux
cette façon générale dans le débat
ordinaire j'aime bien la polémique mais
là j'ai trouvé tout ça à ces déplacés
d'abord on peut se déplacer dans des
zones ice était pas une zone si j'ai
bien compris strictement interdite
mais toi ranger donc je pense que déjà
ses otages vont de porte déjà le poids
de la mort de ceux qui sont venus de
tout ceux qui sont venus les sauver que
c'était quand même pas absolument
nécessaire d'en rajouter
la présence du président de la
république l'a aussi jeudi
on peut dire alors parce que peut-être
il faut probable des prélèvements
publics arrêtent d'aller si steria
quelqu'un qui ait pas d'accord qui m'a
pas qu on pourrait dire qu'il faut
plaindre mais carrick d'aller
systématiquement accueillir des otages
mais à partir du moment où c'est devenu
habituel pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
l'auraient pas fait là donc oui on peut
espérer que la cérémonie mettre un terme
à tout ça qui n'était pas notre est
considérable
est-ce qu'il faut légiférer je ne sais
pas se fier aux médias pour mieux
réglementer effectivement le les zones
où les touristes peuvent se rendre
est-ce qu'on peut aller plus loin ou est
ce que c'est la nature
la liberté de chacun c'est vrai que vous
avez ans a posé une question
philosophique celle de la de la
responsabilité ou fait à la fois de ceux
qui se sont rendus sur place dans une
zone qui n'était pas rouge mais qui
étaient fortement déconseillés par le
quai d'orsay pour ça c'est une première
question
et puis la force de la responsabilité de
l'engagement aussi des soldats qui font
qu'ils font ce travail très difficiles
après notre question si qui va se poser
c'est qu'il ya d'autres otages qui
attendent la nasa une française et une
fois c'est en partie grâce au film est
rhône alpes et rona et donc nous savons
bien que
comment dire donner beaucoup
d'importance à la libération d'otages
c'est peut-être aussi ouvrir une fenêtre
de questions qui sont difficiles à
assumer
puisque nous sommes dans une zone
extrêmement dangereuse on le djihadisme
et quand même
malheureusement en galopant et que donc
des cérémonies comme celles là sont très
importants pour l'union nationale mais
aussi à des envois à mon sens un signal
là bas c'est à dire preneurs d'otages
le fric qu'on accorde à nos à nous
ressortir c'est une bonne chose vous
avez vu que les américains n'ont pas non
pas de la politique
donc ça pose aussi cette question alors
justement on va écouter si le général
lecointe le chef d'état-major des armées
il était justement ce matin l'invité de
rtl
et il revenait sur cette idée en disant
certes on est allé sauver des français
mais il ya aussi pour nous le but c'est
de couper l'herbe sous le pied celui
d'hier aux preneurs d'otages en leur
retirant une monnaie d'échangé une des
vies qu'ils ont beaucoup de prix alors
la mission de ces militaires d'élite
c'est de combattre l'ennemi terroriste
s'est pas spécifiquement d'aller libérer
des otages de manière générale là en
l'occurrence il se trouve que combattant
cet ennemi la façon de l'atteindre à la
meilleure façon d'atteindre c'était
d'aller le priver de la ressource que
représente pour cet ennemi des otages et
c'est bien cela qu'il faut voir c'est la
finalité militaire de notre action elle
est bien d'atteindre les terroristes
il a raison de rappeler cette double
finalité deviendra cette action
extrêmement éclairante c'est à dire
qu'il nous explique que c'est un acte de
guerre
et dans cet acte de guerre il y avait
des otages il se trouve que ces otages
ont été libérés et que c'est une
merveilleuse nouvelle dans cette
histoire mais que le but premier
ce n'était pas la libération des otages
dans un but propre cettex a participé
d'une lutte conte affaiblir les gars de
la vallée c'est une chose que l'on
savait pas forcément qui peut être a
nourri la polémique parce que certaines
personnes m'ont dit mais l'armée n'est
pas une assistante ils ont une
assistance qui doit aller délais et la
précision du général lecointe à mon avis
était utile c'est un acte qui
participent d'un combat beaucoup plus
large contre le djihadisme et qu'il faut
remettre dans cette perspective pour
pour véritablement le comprendre agnès
verdier-molinié je repose la question
parce que ce fut vrai dire n'a pas
vraiment corps a répondu sur le côté et
ce qu'il faut être plus sévère je ne
sais pas par quels moyens
avec les
et touristes ou les français qui se
rendent dans des zones à risque déjà on
a une carte du quai d'orsay qui est
réactualisé en permanence avec les zones
justement à risque très à risque ou un
peu moins à risque c'est vrai qu'après
quand on regarde la carte sur l'afrique
de l'ouest là on est on est ça tient à
un fil quoi à 50 kilomètres près on est
dans le orange où on est dans le rouge
après c'est vrai que c'est la
responsabilité de chacun mais il faut se
souvenir que le commando hubert est déjà
intervenu sur ce genre d'opération au
large de la somalie c'était en 2009
c'était l'opération tannique c'était sur
un voilier il y avait une famille avec
trois personnes dont un enfant des amis
qui les avaient rejoints et il avait été
capturé par des pirates donc à partir du
mount dans certains niveaux de danger
c'est vrai que tout un chacun
ressortissants français
peut-être notamment quand il s'agit de
terroristes peut être secourus dans
quelques endroits du globe qu'il soit il
faut pas oublier aussi qui sont
intervenus les commando hubert notamment
en afghanistan ainsi qu'au mali donc
c'est son effort spécial absolument
extraordinaire ils ont une formation qui
existe quasiment pas dans le monde
on a vu les mots du président américain
en cdi job ingrat
ben oui évidemment parce que même les
états unis s'inspire de ce que font les
hommes du commando hubert il arrive à
plonger dans des conditions absolument
incroyable enfin c'est et les seuls 5%
de ceux qui veulent y arriver sont
finalement élu et peuvent participer que
pour quelques années
donc on est vraiment sur le le top du
top de ce qui peut expliquer exister en
termes de militaires et c'est vraiment
l'image incroyable de ce sacrifice c'est
vrai de 2 de cet engagement qu'il faut
retenir et je crois que ça réconcilie
aussi la france avec ses missions
régaliennes je trouve qu'on oublie très
souvent parce qu'on est on est un modèle
français
très axé sur le social et s'est fait
prendre un peu de hauteur par an on
oublie souvent les fondamentaux de
l'état que sont la défense extérieure la
défense antérieur
et aussi finalement la question des
budgets qui vont avec des équipements
etc etc je pense que ça remet un peu au
centre on regarde un petit peu ce qu'en
pensent nos internautes on vous posez la
question selon-vous l'hommage des
invalides clotilde et polémique née
après la libération des otages
vous êtes 64 % à penser que non félix
nous dit la zone n'était pas rouge c'est
malheureux pour nos militaires et ce
sont des actes dramatiques mais accuser
des touristes ne changera rien ce ne
sont pas eux qui ont tué ces jeunes gens
ce sont des terroristes peuvent et un
mot bien sûr lionel c'est quand même un
problème parce qu'il sent brève pour
notamment ne pas se faire critiquer
après le quai d'orsay couvre quand même
très très largement si on met le rouge
et l'orangé ensemble si à chaque fois
qu'ils auront aujourd'hui qu'on n'y va
pas qu'est ce qui va se passer il va se
passer
qui aura plus de français en afrique
aujourd'hui il ya déjà beaucoup moins de
français en afrique qu'avant mais
beaucoup plus de six mois
est-ce qu'il faut pas il ya des
catégories de français il ya ceux qui
travaillent à ceux qui sont en mission
humanitaire
est ce qu'on allait faire du bon ski
tout cas c'était le cas vous entends
bien mais je pense qu'il est important
que on n'est pas une conception trop
large de des risques parce que oui mais
ceux qui travaillent il faut qu'ils
puissent y aller avec leur famille c'est
a donc
et sinon c'est une certaine façon de
céder aux preneurs d'otages donc faire
comprendre que d'abord quand on prend
des au talent en terroristes on va se
faire tuer
parce que c'est une opération militaire
illégale bah ça peut faire ça peut être
à tort deux bémols et contrepoint ce
qu'on a dit tout à l'heure sur
l'importance qu'on est là je me rappelle
l'importante mais suffisamment aussi
pour aller vous tuer si vous prenez des
otages et d'autre part qu'il faut
veiller à la permanence au renforcement
de la présence de français en afrique il
faut garder ça à l'esprit aussi donc il
faut combiner des exigences assez
contradictoire mais il semble quand même
que la restauration du tragique qui est
arrivé avec les attentes à d'abord sur
le sol américain
puis sur le sol français nous impose
d'avoir une autre approche du monde on
est un moment l'occident a cru qu'elle
était sortie de l'histoire est là on est
dans la fin de la fin de l'histoire est
donc le monde n'est pas un lieu sur
lequel on peut se déployer de façon
touristiques comme si c'était un lieu de
consommation la crue y avait ce texte
très célèbre dans les années 90 de
philippe muray requiem pour une touriste
blonde à laquelle il arriver à une fin
tragique et je crois qu'on a peut-être
trop bu collectivement cet état d'esprit
et maintenant il faut savoir que quand
on parle de guerre face au djihadisme
c'est pas des mots au fait c'est une
réalité et qu'elle touche des zones
entières de l'afrique alors il faut pas
cesser d'y aller moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec olivier duhamel
mais il faut peut-être cesser de croire
que le risque zéro existe encore
quelques réactions sur ce sujet celle de
christophe l'hommage logique des
militaires n'efface pas rendus aux
militaires n'efface en rien les
l'inconscience des touristes la france
ne doit plus s'occuper des touristes qui
décideraient de se rendre dans une zone
dangereuse dont vous voyez nous
internautes sont pas forcément d'accord
avec vous babineau nous dit c'est
frappant le parallèle entre la dignité
des proches des défunts et la futilité
de cette honteuse polémique dont je
parlais n'est pas
parfois il ya des missions qui sont
aussi des motions autres des missions de
renseignement
s'interroge d'adoption qu'il faisait
cette américaine
oui des missions de renseignement et
c'est bien nécessaire pour aussi
comprendre les les réseaux terroristes
qui peuvent à un moment nous attaquer
aussi sur notre propre sol
et ça c'est absolument fondamental c'est
la dg ceux qui s'en occupent et l enam
une émanation aussi du ministère de la
défense notamment pour la france mais
bien sûr il ya la cia etc pour pour les
états unis
donc on peut se dire aussi que certains
de nos ressortissants que ce soit pour
des raisons économiques des raisons
d'intelligence bon pour comprendre
l'ennemi mais aussi des raisons
humanitaires il ya aussi des raisons
humanitaires certains français qui
s'engage pour aller dans la population
notamment sur des questions sanitaires
des question d'épidémie
moi j'en connais personnellement et qui
vont dans des pays qui sont extrêmement
dangereux donc attention à ne pas croire
que l'on va dans ces zones à risque
uniquement pour le plaisir
je note que la par exemple n'avait pas
d'enfant avec par exemple je veux nuancé
donc il faut il faut se poser quand même
la question tout le monde n'est pas
forcément complètement inconscient est
conscient et et n'a pas il n'y a pas
cette démarche forcément de faire
prendre des risques à nos soldats enfin
je crois pas que ce soit ça la démarche
qu'ils aient prévalu et je crois qu'il
faut se garder de juger quand on ne
connaît pas tous les détails et que
finalement on n'a que les cubes et que
j'avais gagné deux verres de whisky à
vous connaître vraiment ce serait
magnifique vous avez raison j'en ai